bonjour à tous merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes bien sur LCP public Senat
c'est l'heure de Parlement Hebdo 45
minutes pour refaire le tour de l'actu
politique et parlementaire avec Michel
zames bonjour Katia bonjour Michel au
pied du mur sous la pression de ses
partenaires alexis cipras a fini par
faire des propositions de réforme sur
les retraites les impôts la TVA les
privatisations il a cédé le dialogue
entre l'Europe et Athènes est renoué
mais jusqu'à quand le cetê grec est loin
d'être réglé cela commenca ressembler à
une histoire sans fin la loi Macron a
bien achevé son parcours législatif la
lecture définitive a eu lieu à
l'Assemblée l'opposition n'a pas déposé
de motion de censure reste une étape
quand même à franchir celle du Conseil
constitutionnel et puis les mesures choc
du Sénat pour l'école une commission
d'enquête a rendu un rapport sur la
perte des repères républicains elle
constate que la laïcité de plus remise
en question parmi les propositions
avancé la baisse des allocations
familiales pour les parents d'enfants
trop absents bonjour ben bonjour vous
être notre invité cette semaine on avec
vous on va développer évidemment toute
cette actualité et bien d'autres vous
êtes ancien ministre député PS des
Yveline il y a une tradition dans cette
émission c'est qu'on laisse le soin à
des parlementaires le soin de dresser
votre portrait on les écoute vous
commentez juste après il a un rôle
particulier je pense dans cette majorité
au sens large du terme et on a vraiment
envie peut-être qu'il joue un rôle plus
important qu'il s'affirme plus c'est
quelqu'un qui me semble très clair très
déterminé dans ses dans sa dans son
travail dans l'exécution de ses tâches
ça par un des députés performant bon il
a des points de vue que je partage pas
tout le temps mais bon c'est un en tant
que député je connais pas l'homme très
bien en tant que député c'est un un
homme qui me semble sérieux je connais
ben Amon depuis très longtemps quand il
était à l'époque le le responsable de
MGS je considère qu'il est qu'il est
dans une ligne politique qui n'a il n'a
jamais varié il est toujours sur la même
ligne politique c'est c'est un respect
qu'on doit aux gens qui sont toujours
dans la même philosophie dans la même
ligne politique là où j'ai le plus entre
guillemets fréquenté bed Ammon c'était
en tant que ministre de l'Éducation bien
sûr puisque je fais partie de cette
commission et j'ai trouvé qu'il avait en
tant que ministre un
regard intéressant avec des valeurs de
l'école de la République celle des
hussard noirs celle où l'école c'est la
chance l'égalité pour tous et c'est ça
qu'il faut aussi dans notre société
alors vous avez un rôle particulier
toujours sur la même ligne voilà ce
qu'on ce qu'on dites vousous vous
pourriez avoir un rôle encore plus
important peut-être sortir du bois
encore plus
non je suis déjà pas mal sorti du bois
ou du gouvernement en tout cas bon
écoutez d'abord j'ai c'est agréable il y
avait des commentaires étaient amicaux
donc je remercie mes
collègues écoutez ça dépend de la
situation je je j'ai pris mes
responsabilités notamment sur la loi
Macron parce que j'étais en désaccord
avec les orientations de cette loi ce
qui a obligé le gouvernement au 493 ce
que je ne souhaitais pas j'aurais
préféré que le débat aille au bout et
qu'on puisse le cas échéant amender ce
texte pour qu'il soit plus efficace il
va perdre en efficacité ce que dit
evasas sur le rôle au sein de la
majorité je crois que elle rejoint
beaucoup de ceux qui aimeraient que la
gauche soit plus rassemblé et qu'on
expérimente un peu moins les alliances
avec finalement jusqu'à la droite et un
peu plus qu'on fasse vivre le
rassemblement de la gauche mais
peut-être qu'on en parlera je trouve
qu'à la faveur du débat sur la Grèce on
a retrouver un clivage droite gauche
beaucoup plus clair et je m'en réjouis
beno on va y revenir d'abord je voudrais
vous faire écouter votre propos c'était
il y a un mois à la tribune du Congrès
de Poitier écoutez parce que peut-être
que vous avez un petit peu changé ah bon
je considère que les militants
socialistes qui ont donné 60 % des
suffrages à la motion a l'ont fait
lucidement ils savaient qu'en votant
pour cette motion ils approuvaient les
principes qui inspirent cette politique
et la poursuite de cette politique alors
je veux vous dire j'espère que vous ne
vous trompez
pas
j'accepte et je respecte ce vote mais
j'espère que nous nous trompons et que
vous ne vous trompez pas j'espère que
cette
orientation nous mènera à la victoire en
2017 qu'il reste un mois après de ce
discours tout tout absolument tout à une
à la à la virgule près qu'est-ce que je
disais qu'en clair je pensais que
c'était pas parce que le Congrès de
Poitier avait une orientation un peu
plus à gauche que ça modifierait
fondamentalement la ligne économique du
gouvernement on va parler de l'Europe
après et des vertus du référendum grec
parce que c'est d'abord le référendum
grec qui fait bouger la France mais bon
peu importe et donc et on l'a vu la loi
Macron elle non seulement elle est
restée inchangée sur ce qui gênait déjà
mais en plus on y a rajouté le
plafonnement des indemnité pour
licenciement abusif quelques autres
mesures qui l'ont rendu encore plus
honnêtement indigeste pour la gauche
donc ça je maintiens et ma ma quand je
dis j'espère que vous ne vous trompez
pas qu'est-ce que vous avez voulu dire B
tout simplement que j'espère que cette
ligne politique ne préparera pas une
défaite qui sera une défaite terrible
pour la gauche si en plus notre candidat
devait ne pas être au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle moi ce qui
c'est ce que je je je redoute le plus
c'est ce face- à faceace qui nous
amènerait à revoir d'un côté l'extrême
droite avec Marine Le Pen de l'autre
côté une droite qui est de plus en plus
réactionnaire je sais pas si on en
Nicolas Sarkozi qui commence à expliquer
que maintenant on va remplacer on
pourrait remplir des des églises
désaffectées par des mosquées ça existe
nulle part bon bref on voit bien et donc
ce que je ne veux pas voir c'est cela et
et euh et j'espère donc et je l'ai dit
euh que les socialistes ne se sont pas
trompés en tout cas moi je continuerai à
à défendre mes convictions on va
dérouler le film de la semaine avec
lundi le dialogue social qui est de
retour à
l'Assemblée la nouvelle mouture du texte
a donc été votée il va repartir au Sénat
puis reviendra à l'Assemblée pour une
conclusion avant la fin du mois on débat
la représentation syndicale dans les
toutes petites entreprises ou encore la
délégation unique du personnel els d'Ava
les changements du Sénat évacué en
commission c'est un texte proche de la
version adoptée par les députés en juin
dernier qui est revenu dans l'hémicycle
et qui poursuit trois objectifs selon
son rapporteur reconnaître l'importance
de ce dialogue social à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise le simplifier en effet pour
queil puisse être plus fluide puiss
puisse être mieux organisé tout en
maintenant les droits des représentants
des salariés la loi crée des commissions
paritaires régionales
interprofessionnelles qui permettent la
mise en place d'une représentation
syndicale pour les salariés des TPE les
très petites entreprises celles de moins
de 11 salariés une mesure que contestent
les députés républi il existe dans les
très petites entreprises visées par
cette disposition un lien direct entre
les salariés et leurs chefs d'entreprise
ils entretiennent une relation
quotidienne qui ne nécessite pas
d'ajouter une échelle nouvelle de
représentation éloignée des réalités de
terrain le texte instore également un
compte personnel d'activité qui regroupe
les comptes formation et pénibilité
ainsi que les droits rechargeable mais
aussi la possibilité de créer une
délégation unique du personnel qui
comprend le ce le comité d'entreprise
les délégués du personnel et le CHSCT le
comité d'hygiène de sécurité et des
conditions de travail une disposition
qui soulève l'inquiétude des communistes
c'est moins d'élus moins d'heur de
délégation moins de moyens et beaucoup
plus de sujet à traiter donc c'est un
recul considérable des droits des
salariés une des seules mesures produite
par le Sénat et conservé par le ministre
du Travail est une expérimentation sur
le CDI intérimaire entre un salarié et
une agence d'intérim c'est un progrès
important pour les salariés concernés un
CDI vous le savez tous c'est l'accès au
logement à l'emprunt bref c'est une
stabilité en plus dans la vie c'est par
ailleurs dans ce texte sur le dialogue
social que le gouvernement a introduit
la possibilité de renouveler deux fois
un CDD mais toujours dans la durée
légale de 18 mois le vote définitif du
texte est prévu le 24 juillet prochain
alors il y a eu beaucoup de
modifications sur ce texte 24 juillet
prochain c'est la date prévue pour le V
tel qu'il est vous le voterez oui je le
voterai oui je le voterai je pense qu'on
peut évidemment aller plus loin je pense
qu'il y a ce texte imparfait mais il
correspond en tout cas un progrès qui me
semble être majeur c'est le le fait de
permettre au salariés des TPE d'être
représentés pour pourquoi est-ce que
c'est utile parce que la droite n'en
veut pas parce qu'elle dit vous allez
créer en gros des des contraintes
supplémentaires pour les chefs
d'entreprise mais des fois les salariés
ont des demandes qui sont des demandes
qu'ils adressent à leur chefs
d'entreprise qui n'est même pas informé
des conditions dans lesquelles tel
salarié peut avoir accès à une formation
n'est pas forcément informé mais oui
parce que pour le coup on allège les les
chefs d'entreprise d'une tâche qui est
une tâche qu'il remplissaient parfois
imparfaitement et qui qui leur permettra
demain d'être sécurisé dans le dialogue
qui s'organise au jour le jour dans les
entreprises mais cette phobie qui est
celle de la droite de toute forme de
représentation des salariés qui donnent
au salariés des droits c'est d'illeur
qui leur permettent de d'avoir une vie
aussi beaucoup plus paisible beaucoup
plus rassurante plus plus sûre cette
phobie de la droite et fait partie moi
des des choses que je contemple avec des
fois beaucoup de tristesse vous êtes
fier d'avoir porté un peu la disposition
sur le burnout cette maladie
professionnel très honnête avec vous oui
je suis fier mais je serais fier quand
on aura vraiment reconnu le burnout
comme maladie professionnelle l'avancée
réelle mais mineur et je l'ai dit au au
ministre du Travail le sujet demain
c'est que vous puissiez si le cas
échéant vous aviez une dépression liée
au travail un changement dans la
hiérarchie une politique managériale
telle qu'elle vous demande un
surengagement qui vous fasse craquer il
faudrait que vous soyez en situation
d'abord un de faire reconnaître cette
dépression comme une maladie
professionnelle ça ne sera pas encore
tout à fait le cas aujourd'hui et
surtout ce qui change tout c'est qu'il
soit à la charge de votre entreprise et
donc pas de l'Assurance Maladie de
réparer et de la guérison de cette
maladie et qu'est-ce que ça change ça
change que ça incite les entreprise à
prévenir le burnout donc à modifier leur
organisation du travail parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a un système qui casse
parfois non voilà
donc je prépare un texte pour la rentrée
sur le sujet ah donc vous allez le
remettre encore une fois à l'Assemblée
nationale soit sous la forme d'une
proposition de loi ou sous la forme
d'amendement au projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale mais
j'ai bien l'intention d'aller plus loin
sur proposition de loi à la rentrée
absolument c'est une des deux hypothèses
on verra en tout cas j'avancerai sur ce
sujet comme sur d'autres vous verrez
vous en avez un petit peu parlé tout à
l'heure on va passer à la loi
Macron et pour la trisème fois le
gouvernement a décidé d'appliquer
l'article 493 de la Constitution qui lui
permet de passer un petit peu en force
sur cette loi dite Macron c'est la fin
d'un long
parcours pour la trème fois manuel Vals
dégaine l'article 4 93 pour faire passer
la loi Macron dès le début de l'examen
du texte le débat a eu lieu peut-être
même d'avantage il a été riche et
intense chaque groupe chaque député
pourra dire chaque sénateur a pu faire
valoir ses positions avec plus de 400
heures de débat des milliers
d'amendements examinés et plus de 2000
adopté ce projet de loi a été enrichi
transformé amélioré libéralisation des
trajet en bus liberté d'installation
pour les professions réglementées
réforme du permis ou encore
élargissement du travail dominical
désormais le ministre de l'Économie veut
aller vite la mise en œuvre de cette loi
qui sera donc l'objet des prochaines
semaines pour que des promulgations de
la loi les mesures les plus concrètes et
directes puissent être mises en œuvre
que les décrets les plus rapides et les
plus simples puissent être pris afin que
cette loi soit dans le réel le quotidien
de nos concitoyens démobiliser les
républicains et l'UDI renonce à déposer
une motion de censû mais vont saisir le
Conseil constitutionnel ils critique la
méthode gouvernement se dit il y a un
ritth supplémentaire à accomplir c'est
le 493 là au milieu du mois de juillet
ça peut durer quelques minutes et ça
suffira je trouve que à la fois la
démocratie en France et puis pour nos
concitoyens le débat économique le
progrès dans l'économie du pays mérite
mieux que cela la loi Macron sera
considéré adopté ce vendredi après un
parcours parlementaire chaotique alors
beno mon cette loi dit Macron est-ce que
c'est un petit peu la la loi sur
laquelle les socialistes sont fracturés
est-ce on reste on gardera que ça en
tête bah qu'il se soit fracturé c'est
évident parce que s'il y avait pas eu
plusieurs dizaines de députés
socialistes qui avaiit dit qu'il ne
voteraiit pas la loi il y aurait pas eu
de 493 donc il ne reste que ça non mais
je vous dites je vous réponds
précisément à votre question que
reste-t-il de ce texte un semble de
mesures don
pour certaines on peut les prendre
séparément pourquoi pas en tout cas sur
les professions réglementées moi j'ai
j'ai pas de désaccord avec ça sur les
l'extension des exceptions repos
dominical présenter ça comme une liberté
parfaitement non pas malhonnête mais
c'est une liberté qu'on prend en réalité
avec l'exigence intellectuelle qui somme
de regarder qui travaille le dimanche ce
qui travaillent le dimanche sont les
mamans célibataires souvent les
étudiants ils le font pas parce que
c'est un choix de vie mais c'est par
nécessit CIT pour gagner un peu mieux
leur vie
d'cité c'est qu'on a on a effectivement
on choisit une une forme de société où
on pense que il faut davantage de temple
de la la consommation davantage de
consumérisme ce modèle là moi ne me va
pas et je pense que il ne créera
d'ailleurs que très marginalement des
emplois est-ce que cette loi va
permettre ce qui était le but initial de
faire repartir la consommation je crois
pas moi j'ai fait la loi consommation
oui je l'ai fait voter par toute la
gauche et même au-delà mais j'ai pas eu
besoin de passer par le 493 est-ce qu'on
était pas dans le réel quand aujourd'hui
vous pouvez résidier quand vous voulez
votre contrat d'assurance c'est dans la
loi consommation quand aujourd'hui le le
parking va passer au tarif au quart
d'heure c'est dans la loi consommation
quand vous avez la possibilité de faire
une action de groupe c'est dans la loi
consommation quand aujourd'hui le
démarchage téléphonique est
véritablement interdit pour ceux qui
n'en veulent pas dans la loi
consommation tout ça c'est en place elle
va servir à quoi cette Macron alors je
pense qu'elle elle a d'abord elle elle a
une entité extrêmement incertaine
puisquelle touche au droit du travail
elle touche à à des
dispositions oui même au déchets
radioactifs en comme ça à la fin
subreptissement et je ne crois pas que
bon ce soit une bonne chose de faire
ainsi
mais bon ce que je veux dire c'est que
maintenant on est Emmanuel Macron va
passer les textes d'application de son
de sa
loi je crois que ça restera un épisode
au cours
duquel beaucoup de mal entendu et
d'incompréhension se seront nichés au
sein de la majorité à raison du projet
politique en partie défendu par le
ministre de om le Premier ministre
libéraliser l'économie et le faire de
cette manière là sauf que on s'attende
véritablement à ce qu' ça a un impact
significatif en terme d'emplo chage non
mais c'est fini je je mais je pense je
va vous dire moi je n'ai pas adhéré au
parti socialistes pour plafonner
l'indemnisation des salariés quand ils
sont victimes d'un licenciement abusif
en infraction avec la loi cette loi
n'est pas socialiste on pas ses
disposition ça c'est une évidence le
premier secrétaire du Parti socialiste
l'a dit lui-même et cette manière de de
gouverner comme ça en utilisant le
493 je d' forte heureusement la
Constitution ne permet qu'une fois par
session et mais oui non mais mais c'est
c'est la marque que cette loi souffrira
d'un
fondamentalement son F d'un déficite de
légitimité démocratique et politique
alors mercredi beno un dossier pour vous
le dossier grec toujours sur la table
des
européen
alors en début de semaine lors du Sommet
de Bruxelles Alexis cypras était venu
quasiment les mains vides en tout cas
sans proposition de réformes et puis
devant l'ultimatum posé par ses
partenaires il a fini par accepter de
présenter des réformes sur la TVA les
retraites les privatisations la veille
le Premier ministre grec avait pourtant
plaidé sa cause prenant à témoin les
députés européens Jean-Baptiste
Daouas il prend le Parlement européen à
témoin Alexis cypras venu débattre de la
crise gre avec les
eurodéputés c'est un honneur pour moi de
m'adresser aux élus européens à une
heure aussi cruciale pour la Grèce et la
zone euro à la tête d'un État en quasi
faillite le dirigeant grec fustige une
fois encore les plans de rigueur
successifs imposé par les partenaires et
créanciers
d'Athène je peux dire que mon pays ces 5
dernières années est devenu un champ
d'expérimentation de l'austérité les
fonds qui ont été attribués à la Grèce
ne sont jamais arrivés pe grec fonds on
ét attribués au ban un discours qui ne
passe pas auprès de tout le monde le
chef des eurodéputés démocrat et
libéraux gu Verhofstad en profite pour
dire au Premier ministre grec ces qure
vérités je suis furieux parce que vous
nous parlez de réforme mais personne
n'envoie la couleur vous ne faites pas
de proposition concrète alors à vous de
jouer maintenant montz que vous êtes un
vrai dirigeant et non un faux
prophète le nouveau ministre des
Finances Grecs a déjà demandé un nouveau
prêt en échange de réforme des retraites
et des impôts des propositions détaillés
doivent être transmises rapidement les
ministres des Finances de l'Eurogroup
les examineront samedi avant de remettre
le dossier entre les mains des 28 chefs
d'État et de gouvernement un nouveau
sommet extraordinaire pour donner à la
Grèce une dernière chance où conduire le
pays vers la sortie de la zone euro
alors il y a un mot qui revient en
boucle dans la presse européenne
notamment la presse grec le mot
capitulation puisque finalement Alexis
cipras va appliquer des mesures qu'il a
qu'il a refusé avec le le le nom des
Grecs est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
ça est-ce que vous pensez qu'il a
capitulé face à l'Allemagne ou c'est pas
ça absolument pas la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui qui a perdu Madame Merkel
et je m'en réjouis moi je me réjouis que
cette politique austéritaire qui
s'appliquait est perdue et donc Madame
Merkel n'a pas les moyens aujourd'hui de
faire sortir la Grèce de la zone euro et
je me réjou perdu pourquoi elle a perdu
pourquoi parce que le peuple grec déjà a
dit non et je me réjoui là aussi qu'un
pays qui dont le poids économique en PIB
doit être 8 à 10 fois inférieur à la
France est réussi à par le rapport de
force politique à nous ramener à
discuter de quoi de ce qu'il demandait
depuis le début et qui de vient d'être
soutenu par la France et je m'en réjouis
le Premier ministre est président la
République puisque moi et d'autres on le
demandait depuis longtemps par le Fond
Monétaire International parce que vous
oubliez de le dire c'est qu'on envisage
la restructuration de la dette greque ça
c'est le FMI qu' envisage mais
pasallemag d' mais ce que je oui ce que
je sache force l'Allemagne c'est
important jou un rôle mais je je je
remarque que ce cette question qui était
soigneusement ensvelie par Monsieur
Junker Madame Merkel et cetera revient
donc nous allons parler aussi de la
resturation de la dette grecque que
Monsieur cypras fasse des propositions
qu'ils disent demain je vais enfin euh
nous allons enfin faire payer l'impôt
aux armateurs nous allons mettre en uvre
un certain nombre de réformes il a mis
ça sur la table mais il demande le
maintien de la TVA réduite pour l'hel de
façon à ce que les touristes allemand et
français puissent continuer à aller en
Grèce dans de bonnes conditions non mais
tout ça je veux dire c'est sur la table
parler de capitulation me
paraîtêtre je comprends que ceux qui
étaient favorbl au oui H qui ont perdu
dont les armateurs au passage dont les
gouvernements Grecs qui ont précédé
monsieur cypras et qui là aussi je le
rappelle ont transmis des comptes
publicqus truqués monsieur Samaras en
tête à la Commission européenne et
Monsieur barazo qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
sur les comptes publics truqués il a
fermé les yeux donc l'Union européenne
a-t-elle une responsabilité éminente
dans la situation de la Grèce oui et
quand monsieur cypras à juste titre dit
nous avons d'abord rembourser qui les
banques grecques qui ont contribué à
accentuer la dette publique comme la
dette privée grecque les banques greques
pardon les banques allemandes et
françaises c'est une réalité et on a
quelques banques françaises moi je me
souviens j'étais à Bery pendant quelques
années je me souviens de la situation ou
du niveau d'exposition qui était celui
des banques françaises à raison des des
prêts inconsidérés qu'elles avaient
consentis en Grèce nous avons ils ont
commencé par les rembourser donc moi je
je pense que la première chose qu'il
faut dire c'est la Grèce doit rester
dans la zone euro est-ce que vous êtes
optimiste grâce à ces proposition je
suis optimiste oui je suis je pense que
le rapport de force politique a changé
de camp et qu'aujourd'hui c'est Madame
Merkel qui
devra
bouger et je suis persuadé vous pensez
on y arrivera que François Hollande
arrivera à la faire bouger de sa ligne à
transigent elle ne veut pas parler de
cette question elle dit qu'on a déjà
accordé des des alligements sur la dette
gre alors qu'elle disent qu'elle ne
veuilleent pas en parler à son opinion
et qu'en réalité le sujet soit sur la
table quand même parce que Madame Merkel
acceptera elle aussi il est sur la table
aujourd'hui le sujet Fond Monétaire
International le président de la
République et le Premier ministre ont
parlé de la restructuration de la dette
grecque c'était la position qu'on
défendait depuis des mois en clair si
vous voulez vous créancier qu'une partie
de votre créance vous revienne vaut
mieux la restructurer et qu'elle vous
revienne plutôt que la Grèce sorte de la
zone euro et parce que là vous perdez
tout il y a eu un débat aussi évidemment
à l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat on
regarde tout ça en
reportage la parole est à Monsieur le
Premier Ministre manuel Vals il faut
trouver un nouvel accord avec la Grèce
devant les députés le Premier ministre a
répété combien la sortie de ce pays de
la zone euro serait un danger pour
l'économie de tout le continent une
sortie c'est à coup sûr des conséquences
sociale politique et d'ordre public que
personne d'entre nous n'est capable de
prévoir chacun des responsabilités à
commencé par le gouvernement grec mais
au nom même de cette histoire au nom
même de nos valeurs au nom même du rôle
de la France nous voulons que la Grèce
reste au corps de l'Europe et la France
jusqu'au bout fera tout pour cela le
Premier ministre a annoncé qu'il y
aurait un vote à l'assemblée si un
accord est trouvé entre la Grèce et ses
créanciers de quoi réjouir toute la
gauche
y compris les frondeurs satisfait de
l'orientation prise par le gouvernement
les élus communistes eux ont interpellé
le gouvernement concernant la
restructuration de la dette grecque pour
eux il s'agit de la clé pour améliorer
la situation du pays il faut aussi que
notre pays obtienne l'inscription à
l'agenda européen d'une grande
conférence européenne sur la dette
réunissant décideurs politiqu et société
civile pour restructurer durablement une
dette publique européenne qui sert de
prétexte à la mis sous séquestre des
droits des peuples c'est pas seulement
le problème du peuple grec c'est le
problème de tous les peuples d'Europe
l'opposition elle évoque le chantage du
Premier ministre grec avec le référendum
de dimanche dernier et souhaite que
l'Europe tape du point sur la table
c'est la Grèce qui a besoin de l'Europe
plus que l'Europe a besoin de de la
Grèce ne l'oublions pas on est dans la
provocation de la part d'un gouvernement
d'extrême gauche donc aujourd'hui le
l'Europe doit faire preuve de fermeté et
j'attends de la France qu'elle soit
solidaire de l'Allemagne pour exprimer
cette position de fermeté néanmoins très
peu sont les députés de l'opposition
prenant le grexit il est vu comme un
échec pour beaucoup certains regrettent
cependant la position jugé inaudible de
la France et un François Hollande qui
veut plaire à son aile gauche justement
restons peut-êtreons quelques quelques
minutes sur sur François Hollande cette
position on a dit qu' était incapable de
trancher une position d'intermédiaire
entre l'Allemagne et la Grèce
on est loin aussi du président de 2012
qui voulait réorienter l'Europe celui
qui était dit qui avait dit l'ennemi
c'est la finance mais non mais si on
veut maintenir l'intégrité de la zone
euro on a besoin que la Grèce y reste
mais on a besoin que aussi des Allemands
c'est qu'on peut pas fa on pourra pas le
faire sans les Allemands c'est le but
c'est pas de tordre les Allemands c'est
de faire en sorte que aujourd'hui
pourant vous dites que c'est une défaite
allemande oui c'est une défaite parce
que il voulait le oui s'il y avait le
nom ils voulaient la sortie de la Grèce
de la zone euro et ils n'auront ils
n'auront eu ni le oui ils ont eu le nom
et ils n'auront pas la sortie de la
Grèce de la zone euro et donc je pense
que de ce point de vue-là cette
stratégie qui a consisté à à vouloir de
ce point de vue-là oublions le débat
politique tous les économies les
politiques austéritaires ont mis à genou
les économies du sud de l'Europe donc
c'est aussi le résultat de cette
politique qui nous dit que ça va changer
vous dites François Holland donc
François Hollande lui il a euh le souci
à la fois que la Grèce reste dans la
zone euro et d'obtenir l'accord des
Allemands donc il travaille quelque part
vous séduire aussi un petit peu dans sur
l'A gauche non mais il il c'est pas le
c'est pas nous séduir non non non
franchement moi je me réjouis de voir
que oui il y a du clivage droite gauche
là-dessus et que de Monsieur chassigne
jusqu'à monsieur Vals on retrouve toute
la gauche favorable au maintien de la
Grèce dans la zone euro au nom de l'idée
qu'on fait du projet européen parce
qu'il rappelons-le quand même le projet
européen c'était quoi et et voir
aujourd'hui les héritiers des grands
mouvements européens de la droite
française être favorable à la sortie de
la Grèce de la zone euro c'était quoi
l'ation tourant du Ken pour Fran la
dépendance économique créera des
solidarités de fête et de l'intégration
politique c'était ça le projet européen
aujourd'hui ces solidarité s'effondr et
bien c'est sur ces questions-l que le
clvage droite gauche s'est reconstitué
en France je m'en réjouis avec Nicolas
Sarkozi qui alors lui pardon mais donc
qui a changé d'avis en 24 heures qui
était pour la sortie de la Grèce de la
zone euro maintenant qui est d'accord
avec François Hollande mais quel quel
crédit peut-on accorder à Monsieur
Sarkozy et ses amis qui en première
option sont toujours à coller à Madame
Merkel il suffirait presque de traduire
un discours de Madame Merkel de
l'allemand au français on aurait la
position des républicains et qui
maintenant change d'avis tout ça
frolland C fation mais mais celui dans
cette affaire d'avoir d'être en
situation de permettre le maintien de
l'intégrité de la zone euro d'éviter ce
qui pourrait être le début d'une
désagrégation de l'Union européenne avec
la sortie de la Grèce de la zone euro et
de faire en sorte que nous puissions
ouvrir un agenda qui pose la question du
gouvernement économique de la zone euro
qui pose la question demain de
l'harmonisation fiscale et j'ai envie
d'y rajouter parce que c'est c'est ça
qui moi me me navre dans le projet
européen c'est la question de la
convergence sociale un dernier mot ce
qui est symptomatique dans cette Grèce
d'une forme
d'affaissement de de toute forme
d'ambition politique c'est la
déclaration et je vais le dire c'est
asse cruel c'est contre un de mes amis
politiques de Martin schuls président du
Parlement européen qui devrait être le
plus
sensible au vote des peuples européens
et qui a proposé quoi que l'on substitue
au gouvernement de cypras un
gouvernement je cite de technocrates
mais si c'est pas montré qu'on a rien
compris non mais c'est pas ça c'est
qu'il explique que des technocrates
serait mieux à même que des politiques
de sortir la Grèce de la zone euro les
technocrates ce sont en l'occurrence
ceux qui ont proposé à la Grèce un plan
qu'elle a refusé et ve voir du cœur du
Parlement européen donc de la démocratie
européenne une parole comme celle-là
cela m'a m'a rendu très triste et je
pense que c'est une faute politique
lourde de la part de Martin Schulz autre
dossier qui vous intéresse B on va
parler de l'éducation et de l'école des
mesures pour l'école une commission qui
a été mis en place sur les valeurs
républicaines à l'école après les
attentat du 11 janvier et les incidents
remarqués notamment dans les classes
après les minutes de silence en mémoire
aux victimes les sénateurs ont fait un
constat sévère ils avancent un certain
nombre de propositions que l'on voit
avec Flora sauvage l'école pointée du
doigt pour restaurer les valeurs
républicaines dans les établissements
scolaires la commission d'enquête sur le
service public de l'éducation dresse une
vingtaine de propositions des mesures
qui font suite au non respectes dans
certains établissements de la minute de
silence en solidarité aux victimes des
attentats de Charlie hebbdo j'ai eu
trois étudiants trois étudiants qui ont
fréquenté le barbare qui a tué le chef
d'entreprise en iszer il y a une semaine
il y en a un qui est mort en Syrie j'ai
vu ces personnes qui n'avaient pas
simplement plus de repère mais plus de
discernement et puis qui se
raccrochaient à un moment donné à la
religion parce que c'est tout ce qui
leur reste mais je crois que l'école
elle a pas rendu elle a pas fait son
rôle en tout cas les sénateurs propose
le retour de l'uniforme à l'école et
l'interdiction de signes religieux
politique ou philosophique pour les
accompagnateurs de sortie scolaire afin
de lutter contre l'absentéisme de
certains élèves ils souhaitent moduler
les allocations familiales enfin pour
les élèves perturbateurs ils veulent
créer des établissements spécialisés
c'est vrai que ça fait très 3e
république nous avons peut-être fait des
propositions qui peuvent paraître un peu
rinarde mais on les assume assez bien de
son côté l'opposition sénatoriale a voté
contre le rapport dans ce rapport on a
ciblé quand même l'islam l'absentéisme
par rapport au religieux on s'est pas
penché de savoir par rapport au fait
juive par rapport aux fêtes chrétiennes
il nous manquait plus que le certificat
d'études à rétablir il y a que ça qui
manque dans la panouplie je crois mais
tout le reste a été rétabli l'uniforme
le voouvoiement punition enfin voilà
autre proposition la création d'une
évaluation de la maîtrise du français en
CM2 qui conditionnerait l'entrée en 6e
ou encore la suppression des tablettes
au primaires au motif que cela empêche
d'acquérir les savoirs fondamentaux ah
oui là je vous vois fâcher que dit
l'ancien ministre de l'éducation que
c'est j'entends alors je l'ai pas lu
encore mais j'ai entends des choses dans
le commentaire qui sont qui sont pour
parti absurd quel les tablettes nous
savons aujourd'hui que l'instrument
numérique avec des ressources
pédagogiques numériques est un des
moyens de faciliter la participation des
élèves au cours et de faciliter
justement l'accès ou la les
apprentissages fondamentaux à condition
qu'il soit bien utilisé que une tablette
si une tablette pour relire ce que vous
lisiez sur un cahier auparavant ou un
livre ça change pas grand-chose mais il
y a aujourd'hui des ressources
pédagogiques numériques qui facilitent
l'interaction la participation mieux je
veux juste le dire aux sénateurs s'ils
ont travaillé c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a
quelques logiciels qui permettent aux
élèves grâce aux tablettes dislexique ou
dyspraxique de suivre au même rythme que
leurs petits camarades qui n'ont pas ce
handicap les cours et d'apprendre comme
eux donc rien que ça et
j'ai perte des valeurs républicaines
c'est un peu ça quand même hein le le
fond du probl fantasme des sénateurs sur
la réalité de la société française ou
sur la société française telle qu'il se
la représente et et et et et dans cette
dans ce que j'entends là et et et
peut-être pas de solution très
opérationnelle je le regrette moi je
vais vous dire parlons de la laïcité
parlons de la laïcité à l'école qui a
été dire et j'espère que ça a été dit
qu'on s'est repenché sur ce qu'avait été
la circulaire de Jul ferry aux
enseignants c'était à la fin du 19e
siècle et il disait quoi et bien que
dans la transmission des savoirs
l'enseignant doit être
juge de ce que peuvent ressentir les
élèves au point de ne pas heurter
parfois un sentiment religieux de façon
à perdre l'accès à eux ça voulait dire
quoi ça voulait dire qu'on pouvait
parfaitement assumer un enseignement qui
dise oui il y a une liberté de la presse
en euh en France oui il y a le droit au
blasphème et on a le droit de se de le
faire et on doit l'enseigner mais mais
un professeur de dessin n'aurait pas pu
faire un cours de dessin sur une
caricature du prophète par exemple ça ça
n'est pas dans l'école de la répu ça ne
marche pas ça veut dire donc que la
laïcité de ce point de vue là elle
protège et qu'elle se situe dans cet
équilibre entre le fait qu'on ne salarie
aucun culte qu'on ne subventionne aucun
culte mais qu'on permet la liberté de
conscience et la liberté de religion
laité n'est pas menacée à l'école je ne
crois pas je franchement il y a se pose
des questions où on demande aux
enseignants chef d'établissement d'agir
avec discernement
mais toutes ces questions sont sérieuses
mais franchement aujourd'hui j'ai
l'impression que certain nombre de ceux
qui parlent de la cité d'abord règlent
leur compte avec l'islam d'abord mais
surtout ils projettent leurs fantasme
sur des représentation de la société qui
parfois n'ont rien à voir avec la
réalité voilà alors on va passer à jeudi
avec la question budgétaire qui revient
au
Parlement le budget 2016 se précise un
débat a eu lieu à l'Assemblée les
dépenses vont baisser 8300 postes de
fonctionnaires seront créés il y a des
ministères gagnants mais aussi des
perdants Samia
deschir recrutement massif annoncé pour
2016 employeur l'état l'an prochain près
de 8300 postes de fonctionnaires devrai
être créés l'annonce du gouvernement été
discuté cet après-midi au Sénat à
l'occasion du débat d'orientation
budgétaire bien sûr qu'on en a les
moyens on se les donne en faisant des
économies sur d'autres secteurs ou sur
d'autres emplois il faut rappeler quand
même que la loi de programmation
militaire qui est en cours de révision
elle prévoyait auparavant une baisse de
7500 emplois pour le ministère de la
Défense vous a certainement pas échapper
que le 11 janvier et plus tard il s'est
passé un certain nombre d'événements qui
ont montré que le risque terroriste
c'est encore aggravé face à la menace
terroriste l'armée gagnera 2300 postes
la plus grande augmentation revenante à
l'éducation nationale avec plus de 8500
postes plus de 12000 postes en tout il a
donc fallu en supprimer mais ailleurs
plus de 2500 au ministère des Finances
autre grand perdant l'écologie des
arbitrages que n'approuveent pas
entièrement les républicains au Sénat
nous pensons que les problèmes de
l'éducation ne se résoudront pas par des
fonctionnaires supplémentaires ils se
résoudront par un emploi différent de
ces fonctionnaires et une réforme
profonde du système éducatif et celui
qu'on nous propose à l'heure actuelle
n'est pas le bon autre réserve des
républicains la crainte de voir le
déficit budgétaire se creuser en 2016
on va poser des questions bien sûr sur
ce thème dans un instant je vous
présente Mathilde Sirot Mathilde cot qui
est notre partenaire du Figaro le scanfr
Katia sur les questions des
fonctionnaires oui alors une question
générale puisque le la ligne c'est quand
même la baisse des dépenses mais il y a
ces augmentations de postes est-ce que
pour vous tout ça c'est cohérent je
juste dire je il y avait pas le retour
image sur le député républicain mais
est-ce que ce sont les mêmes députés
républicains qui ne veulent pas de post
en plus et qui sont les mêmes qui
appellent le ministre de l'éducation
pour qu'on maintienne les postes dans
leurs écoles je je
e que les ment supres nous appite
pourtion vous allez fermer une classe
vous m'en un poste voilà je
parenthèse je pense que plus d'adultes
face aux enfants dans les classes c'est
mieux donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
continuer mainten la priorité qu'est-ce
qu'on peut changer au budget qu'est-ce
qu'il faut changer il y a la question de
l'allocation du cice à l'évidence ce
sujet là est un sujet important parfois
on distribue utilement vers des TPE des
PME qui ont
compétivit entreise le crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi emplo et et par
contre les grandes sociétés qui
aujourd'hui déjà ont du crédit impô
recherche défiscalis au fond de
l'optimisation fiscale je pense que là
on arrose le sable pour être très clair
donc on doit pouvoir mieux allouer le
cice deuxième question est-ce qu'on se
dirige vers une fusion CSG impôt sur le
revenu en commençant par la
progressivité de la CSG qui permettra
cette ce prélèvement d'être beaucoup
plus juste et de moins prendre à ceux
qui peuvent le moins et prendre plus à
ceux qui peuvent le plus j'espère qu'on
avancera dans ce domain là et puisque
vous m'invitez à répondre à faire une
proposition sur l'éducation nationale je
vous en faire
une savez-vous nous venons de faire la
priorité au primair savez-vous que les
enseignants du primaire c'était un sujet
dont j'ai parlé avec Vincent payon avant
Najad valobelcassem après sont parmi les
moins bien payés de l'OCDE notamment en
début de carrière or on leur demande de
mettre le paquet sur l'apprentissage des
savoirs fondamentaux notamment en ayant
un suivi individualisé des élèves pour
cela ils reçoivent une prime annuelle de
400 €. cette prime annuelle pour une
tâche à peu près équivalente dans le
second degré elle est de 1200 €. donc
non je pense qu'il faut porter à 1200 €
la prime qui concerne les 300000
professeurs des écoles en France ce sera
un coût de plusieurs dizaines de
millions d'euros mais là il y aurait une
mesure qui va dans le sens d'une
amélioration de la prise en charge de ce
soutien individualisé aux élèves qui
participent puisque il y avait le
rapport des sénateurs ça c'est une
proposition que vous faites sur la table
sur la table à qui directement au
gouvernementosition de lo encore une
fois ah non non pour le débat budgétaire
j'espère que c'est amendaire un
amendement supplémentaire en tout cas
c'est un des sujets sur lesquess de
peser puisque nous avions l'intention de
le faire avant au gouvernement cé un
sujet dont on parlait je continue à en
parler maintenant je n'y suis plus est
avec nous on passe au
scan math est donc avec nous et vous
allez passer benoî am mon au scan benoî
Amon bonjour bonjour votre discours a un
petit peu changé depuis quelques
semaines NOTAM vous aussi vous notamment
sur deux sujets François Hollande en
2017 et la primaire vous en vouliez une
maintenant vous êtes un peu plus réservé
et vous avez dit cette semaine que ce
n'était pas perdu pour la gauche en 2017
alors qu'est-ce qui vous a fait changer
d'avis depuis le congrès socialiste et
est-ce que pour vous François Hollande
est devenu le candidat naturel de la
gauche alors il y a de question question
importante d'abord j'ai sur les deux
sujets je conteste avoir changé d'avis
je dis juste je si faire une précision
vous avez raison sur les primaires j'ai
pris acte je vais commencer par ça je
pense qu'il sera une difficulté
politique et institutionnelle à
organiser une primaire si le président
sortant est candidat je pense cela plus
compliqué même si j'observe dans un
sondage de tiers des Français ils sont
favorables à gauche même si François
Holland était candidat ce qui monre
cette question n'est pas illégitime et
qu'elle n'est pas tabou mais je je crois
ça plus compliqué et donc j'ai plutôt
tendance à dire que vu la difficulté du
chemin autant se dire que il faudra
organiser des primaires si ce n'était
pas
Hollande le candidat ça me paraîtras
naturel on est évid on a initié procmoc
je ne sais pas il a fixé lui-même des
conditions à
saand NOTAM voilà ensuite la
deuxème question que vous me posiez sur
sur la défaite de 2017 je n'ai jamais
dit je n'ai jamais dit que c'était perdu
en 2017 je dis juste que si on change
pas tel ou tel politique en clair si nos
électeurs ne s'y retrouvent pas bah
naturellement ce qui restaiit déjà à la
maison qui sont restés à la maison
municipal aux
européennes au départemental le
resterait au présidentiel c'est tout et
donc s'il reste à la maison
alors ou bon mais ce que je défends
depuis des mois et que je défendais
avant au gouvernement donc ce point de
vu là comme disait mon collègue enrig
Brel tout à l'heure je n'ai pas changé
just justement vous demandiez une
inflexion c'était le cas aussi pour
Philippe noges qui vient justement de
quitter le PS et le groupe PS à
l'Assemblée vous l'avez salué dans un
tweet alors ça veut dire quoi vous lui
rendez hommage mais vous avez pas le
courage de vous aussi quitter les
instance j'ai pas le courage je suis
sorti du gouvernement moi donc on me le
sorttin me le reproche encore donc je
peux pas dire que je crois pas en tout
cas que ce soit la prochaine étape ça
peut être le par non mais c'est pourquoi
je l'ai salué d'abord parce que c'est un
des député socialiste il est plus membre
du PS mais il est toujours socialiste
euh et et euh et c'est un il agit
sincèrement Philippe nogel vous nen
aviez pas entendu comme parler comme un
parlementaire dire identifié comme la
gauche du PS et cetera c'est un
parlementaire classique socialiste élu
sur un projet socialiste et qui à un ce
moment a le sentiment que le compte n'y
est plus au point que il prend ses
responsabilités et assume bien moi je
préfère dire euh préoccupons-nous du
message qu'il porte euh plutôt que dire
bon débarras comme j'ai cru l'entendre
chez quelques autres ma sur les
régionales parceà force de dire bon
débaras on aura plus grand monde aussi
hein les élections régionales benoî
Hamon c'est en décembre vous avez été
tenté par une candidature certains vous
y poussaient notamment pour construire
le rassemblement de toute la gauche tu
le premier tour aujourd'hui vous êtes
rallié à Claude Bartelone et les
socialistes les écologistes les
communistes partent divisés pour le
premier tour alors est-ce que vous ne
regrettez pas de ne pas vous être lancé
dans cette bataille électorale bah j'y
avais posé moi-même une condition et
pile c'est tombé que la condition s'est
réalisée puisque j'avais posé comme
condition notamment auprès de
l'intéressé que Claude Bartelone ne soit
pas candidat je lu si tu y vas je n'irai
pas voilà non mais voilà non mais faut
faut je vous dis
transparent donc j'ai choisi de le
soutir parce que je pense que c'est un
bon
candidat il a paraît difficile et cela
aurait été même pour moi euh rassembler
toute la gauche dès le premier tour euh
lors des élections régionales en
l'île-de-
France je l'aurais préféré mais bon il y
aura une liste Europe Écologie les vers
il y aura une liste Front de Gauche
l'essentiel c'est qu'après nous nous
retrouvions pour pouvoir garder la
région à gauche parce que nous la gérons
ensemble cette région si demain on va
faire le Pass Navigo euh à tarif unique
qui va être un progrès considérable he
pour les habitants de l'Île-de-France si
on l'a fait c'est grâce à cette majorité
de gauche rien d'autre donc voilà et
d'ailleurs sur le sur le PS au niveau
national h
estz soitile dans dans et que PS
disparaisse des terr ce sera difficile
faudra
êre ou naïf ouou fou pour dire que ce
sera
simple on dirige la quasi totalité des
régions et effectivement nous sommes
menacés dans beaucoup d'entre elles et
notamment avec des inquiétudes dans n
Picardie avec Marine Le Pen une
inquiétude en PA avec Mario maréchal Le
Pen qui permet de dire qu'il faudra
soutenir évidemment les les listes de
gauche et là trouver les formes à chaque
fois d'un rassemblement pour qu'au
second tour euh nous ne soyons pas
condamnés à à disparaître ou alors euh
finalement à même pas maintenir nos
listes pour éviter que donc le risque
final c'est quoi c'est que le PS
disparaisse ah si si on devait
euh céder notre place au second tour euh
oui ça veut dire qu'il n'y aurait plus
un seul élu socialiste ni même de gauche
dans certaines assemblées régionales
merci mathine merci beno mon merci
d'avoir participé à notre émission Katia
c'est la dernière de la saison on trou
l'an prochain bonne semaine à tous et
bonne été ciao
ciao